yeah I just didn't see any barriers to
entry the fact that just because I'm a
mum now like I can't run a successful
business and you know a lot of people
there were a lot of judgments but
ultimately I was on my own Journey you
do you I'll do me you know so when you
said judgments what do you mean a lot of
people take nine months off a year off I
didn't have that luxury my children
bring me happiness but my work brings me
happiness so I didn't want to like
abandon that and I was just really lucky
that you know I've got a really good
support system around me so I had that
sort of child care support on the days I
would go into the office to start to
build out essentially the business you
know as a small team